alors il ya officiellement les résultats
seront en berne au nord barbier 758 46
de plus de 40 2%
qu'est ce qu'on fait à la mairie de pont
de roide
les premiers résultats tombent frédéric
barbier tous ses soutiens ne cachent pas
leur émotion
je pense que ce qui est globalement ce
qui était annoncé a pressenti ce qui
reste préoccupant c'est le taux
d'abstention
participation je vais pas encore sur
l'ensemble des circonscriptions mais
certainement autour des 50 peut être
légèrement inférieure à 5 ans depuis le
député sur ton reste accroché à son
téléphone portable pour mesurer la
température dans les autres bureaux de
vote
un petit tour à son bureau de comptage
pour s'assurer des résultats et établir
la feuille de route à venir il ya encore
du travail et encore du travail
alors mais en tout cas
en train de nous dire voilà continuer à
travailler
il reste encore à tous il faut se
mobiliser il faut se rassembler c'est ce
que je vais faire dans les prochaines
heures travaillées à ce rassemblement
tout l'après midi frédéric barbie a fait
le tour des bureaux de vote
comme ici à voujeaucourt maintenant il
s'agira de convaincre les électeurs qui
se sont abstenus et de s'assurer de
remporter le second tour face à sophie
montel